[Musique]
et pour cet entretien j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau dominique
rousseau bonsoir joueurs de droit
constitutionnel à l'université paris 1
panthéon sorbonne
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je voudrais qu'on reprenne les bases
pour nos téléspectateurs les moins
avertis quel est le rôle précis du sénat
dans le processus législatif
et puisqu'il y a eu cette polémique ces
derniers jours est ce que le sénat sert
oui aux gonds à quelque chose alors
voyez déjà votre première question est
intéressante c'est une question que vous
posez pour le sénat je ne suis pas sûr
qu on imposerait pour l'assemblée
nationale on sait intuitivement
spontanément à quoi sert le sénat
elle sert à représenter les citoyens
le sénat ya toujours eu et il ya encore
une interrogation sur l'utilité du sénat
d'abord parce que dans l'histoire
constitutionnelle français il y a eu des
périodes où la seconde chambre
n'existait pas 1791 1848 il y à des
états qui ont supprimé la seconde forme
il ya très peu de temps le danemark
le sénat est dans un rapport récent
bartolone winoc il était proposé de
supprimer le sénat et le conseil
économique et social pour en faire une
chambre alors à quoi sert le sénat
à quoi sert le sénat le sénat la
constitution le dit il représente les
collectivités locales par rapport à la
firme national qui représente les
citoyens
donc c'est très bien que le sénat
représente les collectivités locales
la question est de savoir est-ce qu'elle
collectivités locales représentent ils
or il représente davantage des petites
communes que les grandes métropoles que
les grandes régions françaises alors que
les métropoles lyon marseille lille
toulouse montpellier bordeaux les
grandes métropoles sont aujourd'hui le
comment dire des moteurs du dîner du
dynamisme
économique politique culturel fait
autrefois on disait le sénat et la
chambre de la seg halle et de la
châtaigne à l'arrivée non c'est plus le
cas aujourd'hui mais il serait peut-être
bien que la chambre haute deviennent
aussi la chambre des métropoles et des
grandes régions là où ceux où se forgent
le dynamisme de la france alors on a
beaucoup parlé de cette majorité des
trois cinquièmes au parlement que
souhaitait emmanuel macron qu'il n'est a
priori pas obtenu est ce qu'il faut de
toute façon un texte de loi voté par les
deux chambres avant même de poser la
question des trois cinquièmes à vous
avez totalement raison lui l'ont bon on
se fixe sur les 3 5e est à tort mais à
tort puisque avant il faut que la loi de
révision constitutionnelle soit voter en
terme identique c'est-à-dire à la
virgule près par l'assemblée nationale
et par le sénat et que dans les
hypothèses des loi de révision
constitutionnelle
le
le sénat a d'une certaine manière le
droit de veto il a utilisé
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas le pouvoir
du dernier mot l'assemblée nationale a
le couvert de dernier mot pour les lois
ordinaires mais pour les loi de révision
constitutionnelle il faut que la loi
soit votée à la majorité en termes
identiques par l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat avant même que l'on puisse
envisager la réunion du congrès et est
des trois cinquièmes et dans l'histoire
dans l'histoire il ya eu des révisions
constitutionnelles qui ont été retoqués
par
par le sénat qui n'a pas voté en termes
identiques par exemple la révision de
1984 sur l'extension du champ
référendaire aux droits fondamentaux par
exemple en 1989 et 90 l'exception de
constitutionnalité qui ne sera adoptée
qu'en 2000 qu'en 2000 et plus récemment
c'est arrivé alors plus récemment non en
2008 le sénat a négocié un certain
nombre de réformes alors plus récemment
vraiment récemment le sénat par exemple
à bloquer la révision constitutionnelle
initiée par jean jacques urvoas je crois
lorsqu'il était ministre de la justice
sur le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
les réformes voulues par emmanuel macron
non cumul des mandats dans le temps
baisse du nombre de parlementaires
doivent forcément passer par une réforme
constitutionnelle alors pas tout un le
lâcher pression la cour de justice de la
république la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature la
transformation du conseil économique et
social
oui en revanche s'agissant du nombre de
sénateurs une loi organique suffit
s'agissant de l'introduction éventuelle
d'une dose de proportionnelle
une loi ordinaire même suffit donc il
faut pas imaginer que toutes les
réformes proposées par le prénom
république lors de son discours du 22
juillet 2010 cette passe obligatoirement
par par une révision constitutionnelle
est ce que vous nous dit que ce soir 15
sénat qui n'est pas ni dans une logique
constructive ni macron compatible un
vrai pouvoir de nuisance pour l'exécutif
pouvoir de nuisance non pouvoir
de frein oui pouvoir de retarder une
vote d'un projet de loi oui pouvoir de
blocage uniquement sur la réforme
constitutionnelle et je crois que le
sénat qui a conscience d'avoir une
légitimité discutez-vous leur a plié
avec votre première question qui a
conscience d'avoir une légitimité
fragiles ne peut pas prendre le risque
de de jouer une obstruction systématique
à l'assemblée nationale donc on peut
imaginer que le le sénat va plutôt
négocier avec l'assemblée nationale
pourquoi ne peut pas prendre le risque
pardon il ne peut pas prendre le risque
parce que sa légitimité n'est pas aussi
forte
sa légitimité démocratique il n'est pas
élu au suffrage universel direct
il est élu au suffrage universel
indirect et l'histoire du sénat qui est
dans la conscience collective des hommes
politiques des journalistes des français
l'histoire politique montre que le sénat
c'est à longtemps été un sénat qui
retardaient des réformes utiles
c'est le sénat par exemple qui a très
longtemps bloqué le droit de vote pour
les femmes c'est le sénat quelque chose
qui va redorer son image ça c'est pas
quelque chose qui va redonner son image
victor hugo disait il est interdit de
deux mètres un sénat le long de la
république donc le sénat adore notre
histoire une
fragilité institutionnelle on ne discute
pas l'existence de l'assemblée nationale
l'existant du sénat est toujours en
discussion donc il va lui même faire
attention à l'exercice de son pouvoir
qu'il entame une discussion avec
l'assemblée nationale pour travailler
sur les modalités de la révision
constitutionnelle le champ de la
révision constitutionnelle
l'exclusion de certaines réformes oui de
là à devenir une chambre mélenchonistes
de nom ou un vrai contre-pouvoir comme
un vrai gagnant mais le contre-pouvoir
il est davantage si vous voulez dans les
discussions au sein des commissions
parlementaires que d'un gène assemblée
comme celle du sénat et lorsqu'on a un
exécutif je pense à benjamin griveaux à
christophe castaner qui m'ont dit on
peut passer par la loi ou par le
référendum en bref contourner le sénat
pour réformer la constitution comment
est ce possible
concrètement constitutionnellement c'est
possible puisque l'article 89 de la
constitution donne au président la
république le choix de faire ratifier
une révision constitutionnelle soit par
le congrès soit par le référendum c'est
une décision propre du président de la
république
encore faut-il et on revient à votre
question de tout à l'heure encore
faut-il que le texte était adopté en
termes identiques par l'assemblée
nationale et par le et par le sénat pour
le référendum et pour la loi d'un jardin
griveaux nous dit on peut passer par la
loi
oui alors pas par le pour le pour la
dose de proportionnelle
oui pour la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires oui hélas le pour la loi
ordinaire l'assemblée nationale et liant
le pouvoir du dernier mot
évidemment on peut contourner le sénat
c'est pour ça que je disais tout à
l'heure que le sénat ne peut pas un
teint est un contre-pouvoir au sens de
la faculté d'empêcher il peut gêner
retardé bloquer uniquement sur la
révision constitutionnelle mais pas sur
le reste des réformes législatives
a contrario est-ce que c'est dans
l'intérêt ce serait dans l'intérêt des
manuels macron donc contourner cette
institution pour faire passer ses
réformes
alors écoutez les gens qu'il peut avoir
l'opinion avec mir il peut avoir lu il
peut avoir l'opinion
avec lui tout dépendra donc le débat va
se dérouler et si le calendrier est tenu
les révisions constitutionnelles devrait
adopter mais juin 2018 quel sera l'état
de l'opinion à l'égard des manades
macron dans cette danse et huit mois
c'est à ce moment là que emma comptes
devra prendre le risque de poser cette
réforme devant les français devant le
référendum pour faire très attention
le dernier référendum 2005 le non l'a
emporté lors de la révision de 1969
le non l'emporté le général de gaulle
est parti donc le référendum est un
instrument qui est difficile à manier
dans la mesure où vous le savez on le
dit mais il faut le répéter on répond
souvent à la personne qui a posé la
question plutôt que au texte qui est
soumis à l'approbation un dernier mot en
juillet dernier devant le congrès réuni
à versailles a annoncé vouloir changer
nos institutions vous faudra absolument
je pense que nos institutions sont à
bout de souffle on a besoin davantage
d'horizontalité on a une constitution
qui a été pensée en 1958
nous sommes en 2018 et par conséquent
les modes d'organisation les modes de
communication entre les élus et les
citoyens doivent être profondément
renouvelée afin que les français
retrouvent leur confiance dans des
institutions car sans institutions il
n'y a pas de démocratie avec des
institutions on peut étouffer la
démocratie il faut trouver un équilibre
entre les deux et ça sera la conclusion
cette émission et de cet entretien merci
infiniment d'avoir été notre invité ceux
là